allez on va passer à l'histoire du jour
on va vous raconter cette histoire qui a
eu lieu à Saint-Laurent DUV juste à côté
de Nice c'est encore une fois une
histoire on a envie de dire on marche
sur la tête une famille de Neu personnes
dont set enfants ont pris possession en
toute illégalité d'une belle villa dans
le sud de la France juste après le décès
de la propriétaire la maison a été
récupérée par le fils qui habite à Paris
mais qui forcément n'occupait pas la
Villa les squatters en ont profité pour
s'installer mais c'était sans compter la
solidarité des voisins qui se sont
mobilisés pour les faire partir malgré
les menaces et les insultes dans un
instant le maire de Saint-Laurent DUV
Joseph Segura sera avec nous je suis
très content de le voir Joseph très bon
maire d'ailleurs très sympa Joseph euh
Segura j'ai vu en plus son la personne
qui travaill avec lui aussi très sympa
ils sont tous venus ils ont dit oui tout
de suite parce qu'ils veulent se battre
pour euh ce ce ce cette famille qui a
perdu sa maison il sera accompagné donc
de Joceline qui s'est mobilisé pour
chasser ses spaturs petit Réap ils sont
avec nous dans un instant c'est
[Musique]
parti malgré l'adoption récente d'une
nouvelle loi anti si squat les squatters
vont être plus durement sanctionnés 3
ans de prison et 45000 € d'amende les
affaires de logement occupé se suivent
et se ressemblent et il y a quelques
jours profitant de l'absence du
propriétaire une famille de neuf enfants
a élu domicile dans une ville C sud du
sud de la France devant les yeux etbahis
des voisins ils apportaient carrément
leurs propres meuble et même un chien
c'était incessant des Voisins Solidaires
qui ont alors décidé d'intervenir
eux-mêmes pour tenter de faire fuir ses
squatterurs alors comment ont-il agit où
en est cette nouvelle affaire de squat
aujourd'hui toutes les informations ce
soir dans
TPMP merci Monsieur le Maire d'être avec
nous le maire de Saint-Laurent DUV
Joseph segurin merci merci d'être là
Monsieur le Maire merci beaucoup merci
Joseline une voisine qui a tenté de
déloger les squatterurs il y a un an et
demi donc la propriétaire d'une belle
villa à Saint-Laurent du Var magnifique
ville j'adore Saint-Laurent du Var c'est
magnifique c'est la plus belle ville des
Alpes Maritimes alors j'ai beaucoup
d'amis Mair dans les autres villes aussi
donc je veux dire c'est elle fait partie
des des des des des 10 plus belles
villes des Alpes Maritimes
non c'est vraiment une très belle ville
c'est V son fils hérite du bien mais sa
vie est partagée entre Paris et le Sud
n'occupe donc pas la villa de sa maman
et là qu'est-ce qui se passe et ben là
allez-y et bien bon moi j'ai les les
clés de cette maison depuis le décès de
d'Henriette que j'aimais beaucoup et je
suis toujours en relation avec son fils
qui donc habite Paris et la semaine
dernière un voisin m'appelle en me
disant Joceline il y a du monde dans le
jardin h je dis bon donc j'appelle le
jardinier pensant que peut-être c'était
lui qui était venu euh il me dit non
donc je monte à la Villa je trouve le
portillon
ouvert qui n'avait pas été forcé et je
trouve deux dames avec des enfants qui
me disent mais on nous a dit qu'on
pouvait habiter là et cela fait 3 jours
qu'on est là donc je lui dis madame cela
fait vous venez d'arriver ça fait pas 3
jours jour parce qu'on surveille la
maison et euh donc j'étais au téléphone
avec le voisin il me dit j'appelle la
police donc la police la-bas qui est
arrivé tout de suite et donc ils ont
commencé à discuter avec ces dames dont
une bon ne parlait pas vraiment notre
langue mais malheureusement attendu que
il y avait SEP enfants et que l'une
d'entre elles a dit que elle était
enceinte
euh nous avons dû arrêter là et repartir
donc nous avons tout de suite organisé
avec l'ensemble des voisins euh
une euh une une repost on peu voà
rassemblement rassemblement on s'est on
s'est tout de suite appelé envoyé des
sm'eston peut faire pour voilà pour
voilà et euh j'ai appelé tout de suite
le fils le propriétaire qui a portait
plainte immédiatement euh dans la soirée
le truc c'est qu'ils sont très organisés
c'est ça l'istoire parce que
racontez-nous ce qu'ils ont fait parce
que c'est ça qui est fou c'est que à quo
apparemment il il s'était ils
connaissent bien comment comment ça se
passe et c'est pas la première fois qu'
qu'ils font ça apparemment ouais en fait
ils sont organisés puisque c'est une
famille qui est connue des services de
police et ils viennent bon dans le cas
pour Saint-Laurent duvard ils sont venus
repérer les lieux c'est ça bon c'est un
quartier assez
résidentiel donc au cœur de la ville de
Saint-Laurent duvard on repère une villa
qui est alors soit isolé soit où il y a
pas d'occupants donc ils ont tourné
pendant plusieurs jours certainement et
ensuite ils sont venus organiser avec
des hommes qui ont qui ont déposé cette
famille devant la villa ensuite ils sont
rentrés par effraction dans la villa en
cassant une vitre et un volet roulant et
là comme vous avez dit il sont très bien
organisés ils ont été changés les
serrures de la porte
d'entrée et c'est ça et lorsqu'ils ont
changé les serux de la porte d'entrée
euh ils ont ils ont pris les alors c'est
l'anecdote mais je le dis parce qu'on
l'a vu on l'a vécu il prenaent le balai
il balayait la cour il balayer les
extérieurs et nous nous étions à sur la
route devant le portail aller voir
balayer donc moi je remercie vraiment
bravo Josel jel et tous les les rivins
c'est courageux de la part de Joseline
parce que alors ce qui est fou c'est que
aujourd'hui euh on s est où cette
histoire ils sont encore là-bas alors
ils sont partis d'accord ils sont partis
au bout de de jours ça c'est passé le 26
le 29 ils sont partis moi je voudrais
dire qu'il y a eu vraiment une
mobilisation absolument entre la police
nationale la police municipale les
riverins qui ont été formidabl et
surtout cette mobilisation vous savez il
y a toujours on a toujours peur des
représailles on a toujours peur et là
ils ont montré qu'ils étaient déterminés
engagés et surtout qu'il ne voulaient
pas de squat dans la commune Gill vous
vous êtes de quel côté là ce soir alors
là je suis moins indulgent que
d'habitude avec les squats vous savez
parfois je dis il faut faire attention
mais là c'est une vraie filière vous
avez raison les hommes déposent des
femmes et des enfants pourquoi parce
qu'ils savent que ce sont des gens
vulnérables que ça va être plus
difficile à expulser ils connaissent
parfaitement les règlements ils essayent
de dépasser les fameuses 24 heures pour
qu'il y ait plus de flagrance ils
changent les serrures parce qu'ils
savent qu'ils sont inexpulsables donc là
non c'est pas des pauvres gens si vous
voulez qui ont besoin d'une habitation
c'est une filière organisée pour occuper
illégalement plein de logement donc là
je pense que l'action en plus a été à la
fois civique civile et non violente donc
je ne peux dire que bravo parce que la
police euh la police est venue elle
était impuissante puisque il y a
plusieurs enfants en bas âge 7 mineurs
au total donc ils ont dû repartir tout
de suite absolument mais quand vous avez
des enfants c'est intouchable quasiment
c'est pour ça qu'il faut agir très vite
et par l'autorité du préfet le le le
paradox c'est que lorsque vous rentrez
dans un dans un appartement dans une
villa qui est inoccupée vous partez en
vacances vous vous revenez de vos
vacances il y a des des personnes qui
habitent chez vous mais il va falloir se
justifier que vous êtes le propriétaire
déjà ouais donc avec un acte de
propriété déposer une plainte ensuite
ben des fois ça me demande un peu de
temps ensuite il faut envoyer tout cela
euh à la sous-préfecture ou à la
préfecture pour notifier euh l'expulsion
le le représentant de l'État bien sûr
c'est ça prend un arrêté et ensuite il y
a l'expulsion ça veut dire que on peut
perdre facilement euh un certain nombre
de jours et vous vous êtes dehors à
regarder votre habitation occupé occupé
et peut-être être délabé aussi parce que
après on sait pas comment c'est ce qui
s'est passé dans cette maison alors
justement parce que alors les
squatterurs donc il paraît qu' ils ont
la tension s'est fait sentir entre les
voisins et la famille de ce squatterur
les habitants du quartier étaient dans
l'angoisse ils assistaient au va et
vient cessant des squatters il paraît
que même vous vous avez été traité de de
sorcière oui oui de sorcière vous n'avez
rien d'une sorcière hein vous êtes
magnifique en plus franchement vous êtes
plutôt une fée qu'une sorcière donc
voilà donc et et euh il y a ce délai de
24 heures he qui est qui qui est quand
même inadm
c'est n'importe quoi c'estàdire que
quand le je sais pas pourquoi on a mis
ça en place c'est ça que je voudrais
savoir parce que une fois les délis de
24 heur passé ensuite c'est très
compliqué d'expulser les squatterurs je
je comprends pas en fait le délire bah
la loi a été durcie les squatters risque
plus mais mais malgré ça même si les
policiers les autorités disent que c'est
pas tout à fait vrai en fait dé facto
quand vous êtes depuis plus de 24 heures
vous changez la serrure à la limite vous
vous faites envoyer un courrier que vous
avez préparé certains font ça c'est
presque chez vous entre guillemets on
peut le contester mais la loi vous donne
presque accès à la maison et comme la
maison n'est pas occupée c'est encore
plus facile n'importe quoi c'est n'impor
ce qui est plus difficile c'est que il
faut si vous me permettez avoir une
notification par le préfet alors que
nous les maires nous sommes confrontés à
cette situation il serait peut-être plus
simple que l'arrêté municipal que
l'arrêté soit pris par les maires
directement dans les heures qui
suivent c'est le problème c'est que le
maire il peut pas prendre la décision je
le vois à chaque fois ici c'est que
c'est ça ça met des délis tellement
importants que derrière ça devient
extrêmement compliqué de les de les les
expulser et c'est vrai qu'on doit
attendre la décision du du préfet c'est
ça mais il faudrait il faudrait que les
maires puissent
avoir la possibilité de délivrer une
expulsion un av d'expulsion sinon c'est
pas possible c'est ce que nous demandons
nous les un peu plus dans le casre de la
décentralisation c'est pas le pouvoir
pour le pouvoir mais les moyens d'agir
immédiatement pour nous administ on le
voit qu' un T qui tourne Paron qu' a un
truc qui tourne Paron là on le voit bien
alors après je vous le dis il y a des
gens aussi qui m'ont dit parce que il y
a eu des abus c'està-dire qu'il y a des
mares aussi qui faisaient aussi des
petites magouilles pour faire voilà pour
mettre des des potes à eux des gens qui
s'entendaient bien c'est ça aussi le
truc après c'est c'est le problème c'est
qu'on peut plus rien faire être maire
aujourd'hui c'est c'est très compliqué
c'est c'est une mission c'est un
sacerdos quand je vois t tous les maires
de France agir dans l'intérêt de leur
administrer et avec ce que l'État dégage
de plus en plus aussi parce que elle se
dégage de ses responsabilités pour pour
les communes et pour les maires moi je
leur dis il faudrait donner l'gion
d'honneur à tous les maires des petits
villages parce que c'est du bénévolat
ouais c'est c'est ce que nous disent
c'est ce que nous disent les maires qui
viennent à chaque fois les maires des
petits villages à chaque fois ils nous
disent c'est du bénévolat et c'est
énormément de soucis et pour pas
grand-chose derrière euh un avis
d'expulsion donc est placé sur le
portail les squatters ont eu 48h pour
quitter les lieux sinon la police était
autorisée à intervenir et les déloger
donc ça a été assez vite
ce cas je trouve que été un cas qui a
été assez vite réglé bravo à J et bravo
à Joseph parce que ils sont parti
maintenant il y a une petite crainte
chez les habitants et chez le voisinage
c'est des
représailles un sentiment d'insécurité
et c'est vrai que moi voilà je suis un
peu inquiet pour jtin et les autres
habitants parce que on sait jamais voilà
comme est-ce qu'il peut y avoir
vengeance non alors d'abord je le dis on
a la chance d'AV voir moi j'ai de la
chance d'avoir Justin comme Laurentine
et et toutes les personnes qui se sont
engagées aussi contre ce squatterur mais
euh vous savez je je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il faut dénoncer toutes
ces actions et pas avoir peur du
lendemain c'est la peur qui finalement
nous paralyse ça et donc il faut agir et
après les collectivités les responsables
nous prenons nos responsabilités j'ai la
chance d'avoir une police de proximité
d'être très proche aussi de mes
administrés et surtout d'avoir aussi une
relation privilégiée avec la commissaire
de circonscription madame Basquin qui
qui fait un travail remarquable avec ses
hommes et ses femmes donc voilà euh il y
a pas de crainte mais c'est la peur qui
paralyse et moi je le dis très
clairement il faut pas avoir peur il
faut dénoncer au contraire et après à
nous d'agir derrière avec une action
très forte ben merci en tout cas jusine
et merci Joseph d'avoir été avec nous
merci Monsieur le ma voulez dire quelque
chose jacquesci non je voulais poser la
question de ces gens qui sont là qui
sont expulsés euh si c'est une filière
le risque est qu'ils aillent s'installer
ailleurs qu'est-ce que vous savez et
quelles sont les suites qui sont données
à ceux qui sont expulsés est-ce qu'on
les poursuit est-ce qu'on sait où ils
vont ou bien est-ce qu'ils sont dans la
nature c'est une très bonne question
parce que comme ils sont venus avec ces
hommes qui les ont laissés en camion
devant le la résidence ils sont repartis
en camion ouais euh et pour partir dans
une autre destination malheureusement
après j'ai plus j'ai pas le pouvoir de
savoir où ils vont mais déjà ils sont
pas sur la commune de Sal randuvard on
fera on fera une enquête de une enquête
complémentaire tiens sur les squatters
ça sera intéressant sur c ce que vous
disz tout à l'heure sur la
décentralisation des pouvoirs parce que
tous les problèmes qu'on voit vient de
là on va le faire assez vite ça sera le
deè ou 3
numéro parce que ils sont ce qu'il a
c'est qu'ils sont très très organisés
ils connaissent la loi mieux que que
tout le monde ici et c'est ça le truc et
c'est voilà c'est ça moi moi je sais que
Gilles Verdez a souvent défendu les
squatterur il défend les squatterur Gill
verd les squaturs qui malheureusement
sont vraiment dans la rue et qui savent
pas voil voilà et qui sont trouvé limite
là par hasard et mais il y a de plus en
plus les squatters comme ça il y en a
très peu les vrais squatters et les
squatters qu' les cas de squat qu'on
voit le plus souvent c'est des squat où
les gens sont extrêmement bien informés
ils connaissent exactement les lois ils
savent exactement ce qu'il faut faire et
c'est ça qui est dramatique et qui nous
met hors de nous à chaque fois dans
cette émission merci en tout cas jusine
et merci Monsieur le Maire d'avoir été
avec nous et vous AZ vous allez être
bien là-bas vous allez retourner
retourner à Saint-Laurent DUV là tout de
suite absolument vous pouvez me
déposer ça AC plaisir merci merci en
tout cas merci beaucoup
allez